you
[Music]
we came out of the river I know it
sounds a little far-fetched but that's
what we believe our creation site that
the story I've been told is where salmon
people were strong people and we come
from this river we didn't come from
Africa would income from the land bridge
from Asia we came from right here we
came out of the water the Creator bathed
us in one hole and then the creator's
rinsed us in the other hole and then he
decided what our role in our life and in
our tribe would be I can imagine that
the river was free flowing full of all
five species of salmon ten species of
trout and I can imagine like the
settlers said you could walk across the
stream on the Salmons backs but I think
the settlers created this place on the
backs of salmon
[Music]
so you can imagine in the late 1800s the
Olympic Peninsula was far out there it
was you know the last frontier in the
lower 48 states and a man named Thomas
auld well arrived on the peninsula I
guess you would say Thomas auld well was
an entrepreneur he was a businessman and
one of the things that he felt was
really holding back development on the
peninsula was a lack of a reliable
supply of electricity and so he went
about securing the financing and
locating the sites to build a couple of
hydroelectric projects when they put in
this first dam it flooded our creation
site and that's where we come from it
was devastating our social and economic
way of life was immediately altered
these fish would swim up here to this
site and they would stop they would
literally bump against the dam trying to
complete their mission there their
journey to spawn before the dams were
installed the Elwha near shore was a
vastly different place for fish and
things that depended on it I can't
imagine how how my ancestors felt when
this big concrete dam was built and
their whole way of life dependent on
this River that was all of a sudden gone
these dams were particularly harmful
because there was no fish passage
associated with the dams these dams were
built in the early 1900's and even
though there were laws in place no fish
passage was allowed so they could not
essentially live out their entire life
the way they were supposed to
one of the first groups that requested
from the Federal Energy Regulatory
Commission that the dams be removed was
a lower llm tribe we wanted the dams to
come down for my whole life my mother's
life it's been a hundred years so we
decided to take charge when the
licensing ran out that was our window of
opportunity there was actually a federal
lawsuit that was initiated by the Lower
Elwha Klallam tribe against the federal
government because of the to inner inner
dams and that the settlement for that
lawsuit was the Elwha River fisheries
ecosystem restoration act this called
for the complete restoration of the LR
River ecosystem and the return of the
native anadromous fish I was joyous
tearful happy but I also knew there was
a lot of work ahead of us it was just
words words from a government we didn't
trust but it was encouraging and we knew
once we had that we could move it there
were continued and significant barriers
to the project all totaled the project
cost about three hundred and twenty five
million dollars there towards the end we
didn't know if or when the project was
going to happen
part of the challenge with removing the
outlaw dams is basically trying to
figure out how to actually remove the
dams no one has ever tried to remove two
dams that are approximately 100 and 200
feet in height so the thing that word
may was mostly the funding and and we
sent a congregation of folks every year
twice a year to go talk to Congress it
shifted literally almost overnight
basically what happened was the federal
government gave all of the national
parks a chunk of money to infuse into
their parks and the park system all of
the parts in the system pooled their
money I'm going to cry gave it to the
Elwha and - excuse me - on what think
national park and said get the dam
[Music]
the dancer coming out have had dramatic
effects on the ecosystem probably the
most visible effect is out of the mouth
of the river where acres and acres of
new estuary habitat has been formed
since these were the largest dam removal
to date in the world nobody really had a
blueprint to go by as far as what to
expect salmon are pretty resilient
creatures they're very opportunistic and
so what we've seen across the Pacific
Rim is increases in recovery rates of
salmon anywhere from 10 to 40 years in
terms of seeing a dramatic increase in
their populations ecosystems are people
kind of perceive them as fragile but in
reality they're very resilient they're
very strong and if you give them an
opportunity to kind of hone their own
way they can do that the general public
can learn a lot from the Elwha near
shore and one aspect is how heart
lifting the restoration project can be
how important it is to work together and
how important it is to celebrate when it
happens there was a there was a big guy
there in the tribes before the settlers
got here we were putting up a longhouse
and it consists of big logs buried in
the ground then you have to lift a big
log to put your roof on so we had a
competition to see you could put this
big log beam up to complete the
structure several tribes try to make
this lift this log but then the Clallam
has got in there they roll the logs into
the water put it on their shoulders
walked out of the water and then hefted
it up in his proper spot so all the
people that were in attendance started
chanting and singing and calling us
clans which means strong people now you
know that we are strong people because
we remove two dams they said
can be done we did it take strong people
to do that and I say we are not damned
Indians anymore and we got our damn
Sabbath back
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]